Aerys Targaryen was the last of his name
to sit on the Iron Throne known far and
wide as the Mad King his was a reign of
instability in terror the Seven Kingdoms
are well rid of him and his kind
oh he may have appeared to be a capable
ruler at first but that was due in no
small part to his counselors led by the
hand of the King Tywin Lannister there
may have been years of peace and
prosperity during arrises reign but it
was Tywin it was really running the
country as Aerys spiraled further and
further into insanity the Dragon spawn
were famous for losing their minds it
was the price they paid for centuries of
keeping the bloodlines pure and Aerys
more than happily continued the noble
sister [ __ ] tradition of his
forefathers as the years passed
heiresses behavior became increasingly
erratic he cut himself so often on his
Iron Throne many referred to him as
Kings scab though never to his face it
was rumoured he had developed an
obsession with wildfire and was known to
inflict horrific punishments on those he
considered enemies including burning
them alive as his paranoia and bloodlust
grew he had a bitter falling-out with
Lord Tywin who had served the crown
faithfully for twenty years at least
Tywin was able to leave the job with his
life and fortunes intact subsequent
hands of King Aerys weren't so fortunate
then the Targaryen went too far the
Crown Prince Rhaegar abducted Lyanna
stark daughter of Rickard stark the Lord
of Winterfell
she was my betrothed she was my beloved
beautiful and spirited woman and I loved
her more than life itself
Rhaegar went south with Liana
hiding her away in Dorne what harm he
inflicted on the poor girl the gods only
know
Brandon Stark lianna's eldest brother
was outraged he rode to King's Landing
to confront the king and demand his
sister's safe return
instead Aerys had him executed his
father
Rickard stark as well there wasn't much
left to discuss after that Aerys feared
their loved ones would seek revenge for
what he did he was right to be afraid
Aerys wasted no time in calling for the
heads of Brandon's younger brother my
friend at heart stark and my head too of
course
I'm sorry didn't come looking for it
himself alongside Jon Arryn of the Vale
the man who fostered Ned and I as
children Baratheon's Starks and Tully's
all called their banners once our
rebellion began the mad Kings days were
numbered